okay so let us start we are now going to
be doing our webinar on how to kickstart
your project your RNA seek project we're
going to be relying on the T bio info
platform and I want to just mention here
and a few words a little bit of an
introduction first of all this project
is sponsored by Pine biotech table
informatics research system University
of Haifa we are doing a recording of
this workshop up and part of the reason
that we're doing this workshop is
because their current users on the
platform have some questions we want to
make sure that this recording is going
to be available online for anybody who
has questions about it but also we want
to keep working on this format of
workshops that allows our users to
effectively analyze their data today's
presenter is going to be Stephanie
recision he's a master degree student in
mathematics and his professor dr.
Vladimir Aquatica who's also the chief
scientist at the Taliban maddox Research
Center at University of Haifa now before
we start I want to just mention that we
have at the T bio info platform the GI
on 4 platform provides a user-friendly
interface for all types of onyx data and
what we want to show today is just the
RNA seek data processing section and a
little bit from the machine learning
section now what we tried to do in this
platform is make a user-friendly
interface that provides suggestions
along the way and reduces the amount of
mistakes that the user can make we also
incorporated a comprehensive machine
learning tool kit and everything is
organized into logical sections as well
as produced some interactive outputs and
just a side note the platform is
extendable it is fairly easy to add new
scripts and new functionality to the
platform and as we get requests for
specific features we are working to
update the platform and make it more
useful
to the people that want to get insights
from these big datasets now I want to
also show you I want to show you a few
things that we will be covering today
okay so unfortunately I don't see a
screen hold on a second okay there we go
okay so let me change my presentation so
before we start I'm just going to give
you an overview of a few things that we
have been working on to make this
platform more useful so the first thing
that we have is in parallel to the
platform itself in parallel to the
platform itself we produced a number of
courses on transcriptomics and a lot of
the things that we'll be covering today
are going to be available online for
free for all the users and you can see
under courses a number of course is
related to transcriptomics of
transcriptomics one two and three give a
full overview of how to process raw data
how to do simple things like
differential gene expression and then
also how to apply machine learning tools
to analyze the expression tables and we
have a few other courses and a number of
other projects that we are working on to
make them available online now we also
have these workshops and these workshops
are focused on specific topics and you
can see some of our previous workshops
that we did this month we are also
planning a summer bioinformatics series
of workshops in collaboration with a
number of universities so if you would
like to join you can email Sahil or
myself my email is Ilya at Pine dot bio
and he was ill at Pine IO or you can
use the chat box on the website right
here and communicate with us directly
now this part of the presentation is
over and let me transfer the presenter
right to Japan who won't take over from
here okay buddy now I'm sharing my okay
he's the presentation do seats is it
available for you yes we can all see it
thank you
yeah great today we will discuss some
approaches to the analysis of RNA seek
data here is what we will discuss first
we will discuss questions how to produce
some expression level tables from row
fast keep an ASIC data then we will talk
about differential expression analysis
and then we will talk about price
analysis and provide analysis or
processing during ASIC data and next
slide let me start from definition of an
ASIC data here's the genome and we have
for example three genes to a B and C and
in real organism example eat the trans
the result of transcription process is a
transcriptome and gene a went to the
transcript a gene C went to transcript C
and we want to estimate expression of
the genes in the sample and what is the
technology first first shattering was
applied so we cut these transcripts on
many many small pieces then some
adapters was obligated
this pieces too it's needed for further
steps of reading and the next step is if
they're amplification after read these
long pieces are read by the sequent
synchronizer yes and so the result of
this procedure is a huge list of small
pieces
oh just works in 80
GNC alphabet and after that we can map
these small pieces to the real
transcriptome and here here is the
general scheme gene transcript reads and
then reads are mapped to the real
transcript and we can estimate
expression level of the gene just by
Counting number of reads that cover the
transcript so here we go
quantification of expression levels one
of the measures is just number of counts
on the transcript on the other hand this
approach is not so good because first
transcript can be much shorter than the
second and if we will just count number
of reads on it we will get equal
expression levels but logic says that if
one transcript is really shorter than
another so we need more reads to cover
the longer transcript to get the same
same expression level so the row comes
room coverage is normalized and two
other measures for expression levels
exist first is called fpkm and second is
TPM so today we will use fpkm but TPM is
often used and all these measures can be
in a linear scale all are in logarithmic
scale often logarithmic scale is used
because it's more useful and we will see
both cases in in further steps and let's
just let us just create a pipeline for
for creating expression tables from the
Aero RNA seek data now I will focus on
my browser hope you see it and hope you
are all logged in the platform please
let me know yet yeah so right now I
don't see okay yeah so I see now the
platform
yeah please let us know if you re got
your platform credentials if you were an
observer and you're just watching this
to learn this platform is available you
can contact us and request access to the
platform then we can continue talking
about that but all the people that
joined and registered ahead of time
we're supposed to get an email with
their platform details okay so we see
this huge platform and we can select
there in a sneek section and we see the
graph and we can make some pipelines for
analysis of our data and first we should
select some options okay first we should
select organism today we will use Homo
sapiens 38 version of genome and
paired-end reads then we upload files
and here we can directly upload file
from computer you know that
the sequencing file are usually very big
so it will take much time and we
prepared some links to our server
because do you see this dialog of a
floating file now or not I click to bulk
upload and I don't know great khali will
find way of main files folder and here's
a file with extension dot SPL all all
the files are already uploaded to our
service server and then we click define
groups and here are our samples
there's 11 samples reads are pair and so
each sample is presented as two files
and in this experiment we don't need
some groups it's just we will create
expression level table for each of the
samples so we click no groups and start
creating the pipeline a pipeline always
start from start button then we need
some pre-processing as I said first
first adapters are allocated to the
reads so after reading we need to trim
these adapters and for this we have a
job
this one and the second is cleaning some
duplicates which can appear after
sequencing procedure so these two
buttons are just for a processing the
data just for dream unused things from
reads and then we need to map these row
reads on their transcript for this we
have section mapping on transcripts and
we will use today
okay - for doing that just clicking here
so data will start from start then for
these jobs and for this and then form
okay to you and then we click end save
then we give some name to the pipeline
okay
expression level quantification and save
after that we can click run pipeline and
it will be evaluated but our files is
really big and evaluation will take some
long time so we so please don't click
run pipeline now we already evaluated it
and have some output results let me
focus on it yes now you see my folders
and here's a folder with results let me
open it now I need to focus on Excel
okay now you see the table this table is
there a result of expression level
quantification columns are samples
UHT 11 sample names and rows are genes
you see a big big number of dreams and
for each gene and for example we have a
expression level in oh I forgot I'm
sorry for in this pipeline I forgot to
after mapping we should select one
second I will do it one more time
we should select we should select
for estimating expression levels one
second here just just one second so do
what we have done through this this
mapping yes and then we want to make
make expression level table and for this
we have a job
cold air seem X table so we should
select it and here are three measures
four units of expression and we should
select fpkm today and then we could
select and sorry forgot it
yep and this is pipeline for obtaining
expression levels of the genes let me go
back to the resulting table here is it
and for each gene and for each sample we
have a number and in fpkm units showing
level of expression of the gene you can
see there are some zero lines it means
that gene is not expressed in all
samples and you can filter out these
rows by simple filter in Excel and we
have a already filtered file let me open
it here is it
it takes some less space okay to you yep
here is it and you can see there is no
zeros and it is the list of genes which
are really expressed in our samples yeah
and what can we do this with this data
because you can see
there is a many many rows actually it's
20 thousand rows many many numbers and a
first first problem with which we can
solve is the differential expression
analysis what is it we have some some
samples and they are divided in
different groups and we want to
understand which genes are expressed in
one group and not expressions or less
expressive in the other group so
differential expression for each we will
look at the same data sense let's let me
go let me go back and create
wah-wah-wah-wah pipeline we should
select human paired and upload same
files and now we can define the groups
we have now eleven eleven samples
actually it's some cell lines with and
one half of them are with cancer so we
can create here one more group by
pressing n plus and drag last six
samples to the second group and first
five samples to the first group so now
the system knows that these samples are
from first group and these from the
second then we press Continue sub meet
and create the pipeline pipeline is very
similar to previous one so we start from
the same pre-processing then we select
mapping with voter two then we are
creating expression
and then we want some differential
expression analysis for each we have
some tools for example we can select our
HR or detective let's select HR and go
to the end the pipeline yep so what we
expect from this pipeline let's go back
to the presentation okay so what we
expect from it
first we expect difference between mean
expression levels this value is called
fold change and you really need to pay
attention to the scale is it winner or
logarithmic because 11.1 in leaner scale
is nothing but one point now one point
one in logarithmic scale means the
difference in two times and please note
that big fold change is not enough for
saying that we have really different
expression levels let's look at these
two pictures at the right of the slide
we see two jeans with their expression
levels in the samples so first group is
blue one and second group is a red one
and in both pictures we see big full
change in this the bottom picture it's
obvious that means are distinct in the
top picture it may be not so obvious but
you see that top the top points which
are blue or we have many
blue points on the top so me not the
blue group is located higher than the
mean of red loop so we have really no
not 0 fault change but it's obvious that
on the top picture there is actually no
difference in expression levels between
samples in some artifact that this blue
ones are such near to each other and on
the bottom one we see really really
significant expression difference in
expression levels so for for formalizing
these things there exist several tools
we change to the analysis of variance of
these sets and they all result in one
number P value so p value is the
probability of observing such or higher
difference if we assume that there is no
difference in samples so small p value
indicates that we have statistically
significant difference between means of
the groups but I showed that we have a
really big number of genes 20,000 yes
and when you when we when you do
multiple testing you should adjust P
values let me introduce some example if
you will toss a coin ten times and the
will and will observe and will observe
ten whoa one second
if you will toss a coin and observe ten
highs you will think that this coin is
not normal but on the other hand if you
will get if you will give a coin to all
the people from Earth some several
billions of people obviously there will
be some big number of people who had
rows of ten attained ten same results so
when we do multiple testing you need to
adjust your key values and adjusted
p-values sometimes are called full
discovery rates
FDR there's a there are another
approaches but we will look on that FDR
today and the third thing that we should
note that sometimes we cal we cannot see
gene with statistical difference in
statistical significant difference in
mean levels but these genes are low
expressive so we are comparing zero with
0.001 and you should also note that it's
not meaningful to to look at these at
these positions the pipeline I have
created is will also run very very long
so we have already prepared result for
it it is in defects pression folder we
can open it with Microsoft Excel and and
see now with no not yes here is it and
see how it looks
so our rows are gene names genes and we
have four numbers first is logarithmic
FC called change so I have already said
it's important to F logarithmic Oh or
not logarithmic so logarithmic vowel
change equal to 10 means difference in
to power 10 to 1,000 times second column
is CPM CPM is a characteristic which
indicates expression level mean
expression level of the gene so as I
said if this value is really low it is
meaningful to remove corresponding
corresponding gene and don't look at it
this column is p value and this column
we suggested p-value approach discovery
rate so now we can filter this table
just by false discovery rate less or
equal than 0.01 I understand my exam is
in Russian but I command this and so yes
now I have filtered that false discovery
rate is less than 0.01 and second filter
is that logarithmic fold change is
between two intervals so on there in one
hand it will it need to be greater than
1 it means difference in two times or
more or less than less than minus 1 it
is difference in two times in in the
other side so greater in two times or
lower two times and you will see how
many how many significant positions
would have about seven hundreds of genes
are
with really statistically significant
difference in mean level of expression
yes so it's HR and there is a number 2 D
SEC - one second yes we have a result of
DC - and you should note that a result
of two different tools can be
essentially different different so they
use different statistical frameworks and
results can be different for example
deseg - usually gives more significant
positions than our chart
yessum now we as I understand me one
second okay now we created the pipeline
and I think that's all about
differential expression level next we
will okay I see crazy plan yeah okay
just wanted to point out look so so
healthy filters genes with low
expression what cut or do you use this
question is difficult and sometimes I
think that you should look at
corresponding positions in separate so I
don't think that there is a general
approach to cutting off so you can draw
for example Instagram and C and take a
number of points with really low
expression in comparison with and with
other with other genes so I don't think
that I can said that there is a unique
threshold for all for all problems but
in general in general
you mentioned filtering the expression
table so you filtered out the zeros
right so those genes that are zero
across all of the all of the samples yes
so I have removed the yeah yeah yeah and
then when you say the low expression I
mean you didn't filter anything in your
table but would you do something with
your table before moving on to the next
step I think that zero rows are cutted
by H bar too so I don't think that we
need to do it in the manual way so in in
table which I showed one second in this
table there are no positions with really
zero mean average expression level and
but you can see that there are really
positions with negative expression level
in order a big scale and I think that in
that looking at other numbers like for
Sikhs we can say that for example this
gene is the result of low expression and
we could remove it and don't look at it
so if we see that other numbers are
really relatively big we can estimate it
cut off for current problem so I don't
think that there exists one unique
cutoff for all tasks in our world okay
so if
there are any more questions please feel
free to ask them in the chat and there
is done we can go further and we have
some question from the previous workshop
the question is how where how can we
work with not human organisms and you
see that in two TBA by only four
platform we have a lot of other
organisms except Homo sapiens and if you
have an organism which is not least at
you you can choose your genome and
upload it to so this platform is aimed
on on an arbitrary a genome arbitrary
organism and you can work not only with
human okay
there is no patience we will we will
continue okay and now we'll we talked
about how to generate SPL beings today
as well links is a links to to the files
on our server so for obtaining this link
you should upload the file to the server
and ask some someone from their
administrators to send this link to you
so this is dresser this is our current
preparation we've already uploaded it to
the server and I think I have asked your
question so today we will not upload any
file any big files and gets as my own
wings to them
okay so as well link is adjust a path to
the file bone on the server not
something special okay and let us wait
some seconds there are more questions
okay let's continue and let's speak
about unsupervised analysis in previous
example we have 11 samples with which
are already separated into two groups
but sometimes we have some samples and
we do not know if there exists some
partitioning groups which can be really
meaningful and this is a topic of
unsupervised analysis so we have some
number of special samples and we want to
understand can we divide it into some
groups to see some meaningful partition
and I will demonstrate you two
approaches and the first approach is the
principal component analysis for
accessing it we should select
unsupervised analysis section here and
what is principal component analysis
imagine that we have only two genes in
each sample only two this funny
situation but if there are only two
genes then we can draw each sample on
the plane just two coordinates
expression of the tooth of the first
gene and the second gene and we have
some kind of I don't know 10 or 20
samples we can draw them on the plane
and see these terms are about on these
stands are at the bottom of the plane
and we see natural division to the
groups but as you see we have 20,000
genes and it will be difficult to draw
them in plane but we will take some
projection let me show you my webcam and
demonstrate what is principal component
analysis now you see me and as you know
I am a three-dimensional object but
actually you see my two-dimensional for
the projection on the plane of your
screen and let take a pencil now into
the projection of three-dimensional
pencil if I will orient it like this you
see just some little circle so you don't
see nothing and you can say that this is
a pencil on the other hand if I will
turn it this way you see that this is
actually a pencil and you see that it's
a circle and it's some kind of segment
so the idea is to maximize the variance
of our set at the projection and what's
the principal component analysis do but
for the high dimensional case so let our
let us apply some files we will a close
expression table this is the main files
folder and we have here cell lines
expression data now we upload it by
default load note as well links wait for
it being loaded then press Continue
start okay Pedro and here's
some default arguments and then go to
the end say event and after that we can
run the pipeline it's not so long as the
other pipelines like mapping or
obtaining expression table but let us go
to the results not to waste some time
and here is PCA folder and we have a PDF
the picture which the job needs now I
will show you to eat
show it to you okay here's the
projection of the data to the to the
plane and you see that in the left we
have one group and the right we see the
second group so PCA is just the method
to just method to see by your eyes so
it's not automatically procedure you
just draw and look at it and in this
case it's obviously separation into at
least two groups we could look at first
and third principle components you will
see the partition two and second and
third I don't know if you can see
something in this picture but not okay
and the one more case when you have some
partition to the groups and you want to
understand if they are really distinct
so for example we have input
expression that and marked we can open
it with Excel here's a table with a huge
number of samples we have about 50
samples and each sample is marked as
some group so it's some cancer cell
lines and you can see some groups and we
want to visualize it by principal
component analysis too but we want to
see the plane with points colored by the
original groups you see our pipeline
already finished and here how it looks
like here's your results you can
download this PDF open it ok now we will
run another one pipeline one second we
go here start ok ah I forgot to upload
some files files marked ok we just we we
just repeat the same procedure so start
PC drew and and and not to waste time I
can show the result don't think that's
important now to see the approach is one
more time and here's the result
here we see the four groups and we see
that one of the groups luminol is really
separate is separated on the plane of
first two principal components and the
free other are just mixed up
at the plane of first and third
principle components we see that
actually bezel group is only distinct
with other two and on the last one we
see nothing and meets normal second and
third component does not contain a lot
of information such the first principle
component and that's about principle
component analysis and for your job you
may need to modify this plot or add
something new and you can see that in
output files of this pipeline we have
something called PCA our Park the Jeep
we can extract it terse Department and I
see your PowerPoint or your fishing
sorry yes here I focused now to the
folder sorry we have an active PCA our
part at the output of the pipeline we
can extract it and here we have our
script which performs all the job let me
open it with this not good one second
okay I will open it with Microsoft Word
it is open now ok and here is a code and
for example you may want to add a title
to the picture and you can find here the
line which performs plotting skull of Gd
quad function and you can add there
something like apps
title equal to I don't know some hello
world and if you will run this code you
can see that in this folder we have we
have one more file let me open it with
notepad and it contains information
about how to run this in it with our so
here are arguments just input file and
for arguments which I need to be passed
to that PCA okay so you can modify the
script and obtain some of the results
where's my presentation there isn't
that's all about unsupervised analysis
and the next problem is supervised
analysis with some slides about here are
your URL clustering it's an alternative
to the PCA which results in the
following picture here is some
instruction how to run it just start
each class and and here's some options
and the result of this procedure is
dental gram it's a 3/8 is the rate of
dissimilarity of of the samples so the
more down you go the more samples are
similar and from this dendrogram we see
that we can speak about four clusters
for example this is the first cluster
first group group and cluster are
synonymous this is the first second
third and the fourth one next are not
meaningful because they are really
similar similar to each other
and no need to separate them into into
different clusters different groups and
now about supervisor analysis I want to
supervise the analysis let me show you
input files and it will be much easier
to understand it looking at these files
suppose you have some samples which are
divided into groups let's look at the
same the same table we have some samples
and some six groups six classes and then
suppose we have one more sample and we
do not know to which it corresponds for
example let's open test file and here we
see two samples with their expression
levels and women and we do not know to
which group each sample correspond and
we want to train a classifier on
previous data set and evaluate each to
make prediction on these two samples so
that purposes we have let me focus back
we have a supervised analysis section in
the platform there are workflow we
similar to previous ones we just upload
two files train and test wait until they
okay then press Continue and start their
workflow you see several methods today
we will use as we stepwise LD a linear
discriminant analysis
because our tables contain a lot of
features 20,000 genes is a much bigger
than number of samples so nave applying
of some other classifiers leather-like
random forest or SVM will cost in not
meaningful results there's some
meaningless classification but stepwise
Lda
performs feature selection inside of an
algorithm so it really can work with our
data and here we need to modify one of
the threshold so the algorithm set it to
0.005 just add add one zero the after
decimal point click Save and go to the
end we can write around this pipeline
stepwise Lda will take some something
about 5 minutes so I think I can show
you the results now not to wait until it
will work yeah and let's look with what
predictions it made predictions are in
spld a prediction test file we can open
it via for example Excel yeah and here
we see sample name and predicted class I
have removed these two samples from the
previous BigTable and actually I know
which classes are correct and
I can say to you that these predicted
class classes are correct so Crucifier
answer resulted in correct answer in
both cases so please sample is a really
normal life at this sample is really
basal yeah so this classifier really
works
and the last thing that I want to want
to discuss let's open this file with
coefficients yes these are some genes
which stepwise Lda extracted as the most
meaningful genes to making predictions
so here we see some ensembl ids of the
genes and if you are normal human you
can't understand which this screen means
yes you need some description about this
about this team and first approach is
just copy this name and past in Google
and see what is it or the second
approach or the normal approach is to go
to the platform go to the utility
section and select your annotation
annotation button we can upload close
the file we're gonna pull the file press
Continue start annotation and the end
okay we can run it and the result of
annotation will be will be a table let
me show to you yeah here is it we can
remove now this these columns we can
remove them yeah and we we have a table
with annotation just all information
which you can run from the example
website yes Jen assemble some short
description and other other so all
information about June by its and sample
ID okay and have it finished you you see
that SB L v8 is processing now so it's
good that I showed the results already
okay so now okay so now some summary
what we have done today first we have
analyzed some approaches to obtaining
expression level tables then we spoke
about differential expression analysis
about detect U and H R and then we
talked about supervised and unsupervised
analysis if we do not have an additional
information about groups
we can apply unsupervised approach for
example PCA
visualization and looking just to the
teacher or your article clustering or
some other kind of clustering and if the
samples are divided into groups we can
perform supervised analysis to
understand to which class to which group
new sample belongs yeah I think that's
all you can ask questions yeah so please
ask questions we want this workshop to
be also an opportunity for you to start
your own projects so I know that there
are some technical questions that come
up as you try to upload files questions
around what formats you are able to
upload and what parameters to set in
some preliminary steps so this this is
the time to ask those also there might
be questions about some non-standard
ways to process data so this was an
overview of a standard RNA seek you can
do a lot more with next-generation
sequencing data but we can cover that in
separate workshops or in one-on-one
conversations we also have these
different sections like supervised and
unsupervised machine learning and there
a number of other methods there and
you're welcome to try those just to
capture the difference the difference is
that in one you process raw ask you or
fast the files in the second one you
work with tables and I think that was
demonstrated in the workshop also as a
conclusion you get something
visualization in some of the algorithms
not all of them produce visualization
but typically you can open a table in
Excel and do some kind of simple chart
in there and so we saw a little bit of
that also today so
hopefull let's make it clear how to get
started and how to upload your files if
you need help uploading large files of a
lot of samples if you're already using
the platform to keep reusing the file so
let's say you started one our NAC
pipeline and then you want to try
another differential expression pipeline
it's very helpful to have those files as
SVO links because then you can reuse
them and don't have to upload them many
times just contact us and let us know
about it right now we have a number of
users on the platform and we are
monitoring how much space and how much
resources are being allocated towards
each project and so we help minimize the
mistakes and different technical issues
that come up by helping to make sure
that everything is uploaded and stored
in the right place okay and then okay
yeah so Jing is asking about fast q dot
G yes you can upload those now they will
work fine okay so the fast Q dot GZ
files get unzipped inside the begin
folder now and also it would be great
again just as a reminder if you have
more than several samples and you want
to have access to those samples in many
different pipelines and it's good to
upload them and we will provide you with
the links to those files as the air
links and also if you want to take a
look at some of the details of what we
use today some of the links that we used
all of these links so again these are
real files with SVL or tables all of
those are located on the workshop page I
will paste the link here once again so
that everybody
has the link and on this link okay sorry
let me make it to everyone so on this
link you if you scroll down you can see
files for download and there's an orange
button download file so you can just
download this here let me quickly share
my screen okay so as you can see my
screen this is the link I gave you you
can go down here you can download the
file and you can also download this
presentation so when you go to click on
download file you will see you will see
the workshop file zip and within the zip
you have the presentation you have the
input files and these are the SPL files
and then you have all of the output
files all of this is just to help you
get started if you want to play around
with the platform and you have the
credentials to access the platforms it's
very simple you use upload and then you
can use some of these files to just get
started now you also can download files
from something like geo or if you have
your own files so if you have any
questions about that just let us know
all right well I hope that this was
helpful we will continue and expand on
these workshops in the near future we
are planning a more comprehensive
hands-on series of workshops that we
will also schedule in person and I want
to just conclude with a couple of dates
so in May around the middle of May we're
going to have hands-on workshops in a
number of places in the US we will also
offer those online and then we also will
have summer workshop a summer series of
workshops and in the summer if you can
let us know that you're interested we
are still planning the locations we're
thinking to start this around June so
please reach out to us and that that's
about it if you don't have any other
questions we are going to end here so
again thank you to step on and for
sharing the slides and going through the
steps and thank you for everybody else
that attended and please stay in touch
thank you thank you thank you
you